los familiares de las víctimas de los
ataques de christchurch se reunieron en
un tribunal de wellington para muchos
esta fue la primera vez que pudieron
interrogar al hombre que mató a sus
seres queridos el 15 de marzo del año
pasado
constantemente trató de imaginar cómo se
sintió mi querido ata en el momento del
ataque como se enfrentó al asesino con
el pecho armado solo con su coraje como
los demás que había en su mente cuando
se dio cuenta de que se iba a ir de esta
vida a su último viaje
a enterrar a un amigo es desgarrador
pero que tales enterrar a una persona
muy especial que mi hijo ata y 49 amados
hermanos y hermanas de una sola vez
fueron muchos testimonios impregnados de
dolor pero también de fuerza una víctima
dijo que su comunidad y su fe eran más
fuertes que nunca
mi corazón está roto pero nosotros no
estamos rotos al contrario nos hemos
unido más el joven de 29 años vengeance
arancia se declaró culpable de 51 cargos
de asesinato en marzo los fiscales
destacaron la premeditación de estos
ataques terroristas indicaron que el
supremacista blanco había acumulado
miles de rondas de municiones
bolt un trono para el reconocimiento de
los lugares e investigó minuciosamente
la disposición de las mezquitas su
objetivo había planeado quemarlas y
atacar una tercera se espera que el
australiano sea la primera persona en
nueva zelanda en ser sentenciada a
cadena perpetua sin libertad condicional